thank you mr speaker mr speaker a few  weeks ago i commissioned an independent  inquiry into a series of events in  downey street in the cabinet office as  well as some other whitehall departments  that may have constituted potential  breaches of the covid regulations that  process has quite properly involved  sharing information continuously with  the metropolitan police so i welcome the  mets decision to conduct its own  investigation because i believe this  will help to give the public the clarity  it needs and help to draw a line under  matters but i want to reassure the house  mr speaker and the country that i and  the whole government are focused 100  on dealing with the people's priorities  including the uk's leading world role in  protecting freedom around the world